vise effectivement à excuser moi à la
fermeture la fermeture de plusieurs
réacteurs nucléaires
les vise également à donner à donner
corps à donner à donner corps à la
transition énergétique
mesdames et messieurs les députés de la
france soumise et consorts à prendre
date et consorts oui oui et consorts à
prendre date prise en charge de ça je
n'arrive plus à lire
voilà en tout cas tout ça pour vous dire
que le scrutin est clos
voilà
n'avait pas eu le temps d'appuyer sur le
bouton consacrer une vraie consacrée
j'ai encore rien dire un set je pensais
qu'on micros étaient coupées et je
réagis c'est un message que j'avais reçu
par sms voilà